- Squid Game!
Apparently there's a lot
of medical scenes in it!
I watched a few episodes,
if you didn't, spoiler alert.
Let's get started!
Pe-woop!
(Screaming)
- Come on, let me see
poor thing
- I don't think I have to
explain to you why eating
someone's blood is a bad
thing, infection, disease
- Ah,
got a sweet taste to it.
- What's he have diabetes,
did he just diagnose him with
diabetes? Back in the day. If
you had uncontrolled diabetes,
your urine would have a fruity
odor to it. That's where
diabetes mellitus came from.
- Didn't your mom ever teach you to
not get in a car with strangers?
- (Robotic Voice) Stranger danger!
(Chemicals spraying)
- See, I need an
anesthesiologist right now
because I don't know what this gas is.
I wanna know what gas they're using.
If you know comment down below.
(Violins playing)
- This scene here is really cool,
but there's a few
improbable factors happening
at the same time.
How did they all wake up
simultaneously at the same
exact time If they were given a chemical?
chemicals have different excretion points
in different individuals.
I'm gonna have a certain set of effect,
you may have a different set of effect.
How do they all wake up uniformly?
- [Robotic girl] Green light!
(People running)
Red light!
(Motors working)
(Aiming/Targeting sounds)
- [Robotic voice] Player 324, eliminated!
(Gunshot fires)
(Player 324, vomits)
- Oh, that's internal bleeding!
(Gunshots being fired)
Oh, medically,
I think you and I have the same
understanding of what's happening.
(laughing)
This old man
- [Robotic girl] Red light!
- [Mike] Why does he have
a huge smile on his face
watching this?
(Devils laughing)
(Happy upbeat music)
You know what just happened?
He tore his A.T.F.
His anterior talofibular
ligament, just like me!
I just got my M.R.I done, I tore it!
If momentum's carrying you
forward and you're falling
for someone to grab you while
they're leaning forward,
you just have to be jacked diesel.
(screams)
There's no way you're doing it
especially this guy
with his frame, no shot!
Game number one, in squid
game, not compatible with life!
Unless you can get passed a lie,
then compatible!
Woo!
- [Doctor] She's diabetic.
- [Mike] When a patient's diabetic,
they have poor circulation
to their lower extremities,
and you don't have white blood cells going
to fight the infection in that area,
therefore, you get a
worsening infection, gangrene.
Which leads to an amputation.
- [Doctor] She had to be
in a lot of pain, recently.
- That's not true, because you're having
your nervous system suffer,
you actually might not feel
that you have such a bad infection
in your lower extremities.
- Will you be able to treat her for it?
- In the worst case,
she might need to have
her feet amputated, let's
keep her here for now.
- And treatment here is I.V. antibiotics,
and wound cultures to see if
the antibiotics are appropriate.
- Huh, give it to me.
- Let me go you son of a-
- Give me my money
(Screaming)
- This is an incredibly painful injury,
you have a ton of nerve endings
in your finger tips and your hand,
that's why your able
to do very fine motor control.
Two-point discrimination,
where if you have two,
pins touching your fingers
you can tell a difference between them,
even though they're really close together.
So getting your had crushed like that,
obviously very painful, also
you can't use your hand again,
it will have to be
amputated, the rest of it.
You can't just put it back together like
you can with a fracture.
- Jerk, how's this huh?
- Ooh, That was a good form
on the punch, you don't want
to do one of these wide things.
'cause I'm boxing lately.
- Hip kick, Hip kick, Rib kick
Did he die of his-
look at this bear hair on me.
I mean he must've done
some powerful kicking
(powered up explosion sounds)
the one way you can die in
that situation is obviously
internal bleeding but what could
be more dangerous is if you
kick the rib, the rib fractured
and actually punctured
a lung, he then had a
pneumothorax with a collapsed lung
and because of that he wasn't
able to profuse his body
and as a result, he died.
Again with the neck cracking,
Stop with the neck cracking.
- I would now like to welcome
you all to the third game.
- My favorite game.
- Tug of war.
- Tell me you don't want to
be one of those for Halloween?
Just tell me.
(People screaming)
When you're falling from that
height, everything breaks
everything splatters 'cause
you're essentially going from
a really fast speed to a complete stop.
Um,
Incompatible with life.
- He's not breathing, go get that doctor.
- Didn't he just like
fall down a massive height
and he's not breathing.
Is that a liver?
Looks like a liver.
How about some ice for that liver?
Ideally when you're transporting
organs that have been
harvested for donation,
their viability after death
varies depending on which
organ you're talking about.
The heart for example, probably
the shortest lived one,
4 to 6 hours, Ideally you
want to keep them cold.
Almost like a refrigerator.
This fluid that they're putting
the organs in is probably
some sort of preservation fluid
to help protect the organs
from the cold that they're
about to be put into.
- I bet I could do it if
you teach me a few tricks.
- Yeah, you think all of
this is so simple huh?
- I saw on the news doctors
don't always perform
surgeries. Sometime it's the
office managers or nurses
aides.
- I don't know if this is
supposed to be comedy or not,
if you know a surgeon who is
allowing their office managers
to perform surgeries, call
the medical board, call 911,
call somebody 'cause that
shouldn't be happening.
- We didn't even get full
price because it only
had one kidney.
- You can live without a
kidney, you could actually live
without multiple organs. Lungs,
kidneys, tonsils, appendix,
gall bladder, and a few
more that I'll mention in
future videos.
- My doctor said counting is
good so I don't get dementia
or anything.
- The brain and the theory
of 'if you don't use it,
you lose it' is quite true.
Muscles, you don't use
them, they atrophied.
Your brain, you don't
challenge it, you actually
start fading.
- The cow goes moo.
- So by staying active, by
keeping social connections,
by counting who's around
you and doing sodoku puzzles
that actually keeps you sharper
longer. It's been proven.
- Doctor said there's a
lump inside over here.
Growing everyday. Brain tumor.
- You know not all brain tumors
are fatal. There are some
brain tumors that can be
operated on, and obviously
it depends on the type
of brain tumor and where
in your brain it actually is.
- What's going on?
You're burning up.
- No no, it's fine.
- Fever is obviously a sign
of infection, and a fever
by the way, is a good thing.
It's your survival mechanism.
Your immune system works
better when you have a fever.
Generally speaking, if
you're a healthy person,
taking antipyretics,
medications that lower your
temperature, it's strictly
for your comfort, not for
actual benefit.
- We need to lower your fever a lot.
- See that he want's to
lower his fever for comfort.
The fever is actually
working in his interest
to keep him alive.
(Sirens blaring)
- If you lost control over your urination,
you're probably septic.
Your altered mental status,
your blood pressure's dropping,
you can't get up and walk around.
- Sir, we have to play now.
We gotta start right now.
- Play what?
- With our marbles, let's go.
- This is a direct symptom of
A.M.S. altered mental status
feeling out of it, disconnected
from reality, I've seen
patients say some really
terrible things to
their own family members even.
- Oh, wow, okay, I know
what she's about to do,
I also wish she would wrap
at least some paper around it
so at least she's not ripping
sharp glass with her hand.
No, just leave it in.
Oh no
This is terrible.
Once you start piercing
the bowel, you essentially
start having a scape of
bacteria into the gut.
And when that happens, you
start getting an infection
of the entire abdomen.
You essentially die.
Without treatment of course.
I don't know how she's going to survive.
Like you just gotta put
pressure and hope for the best
at this point.
- Take another step and,
(Gunshot fire)
- He just ate that bullet
like a champ. Just bam.
I hope he's wearing a vest.
He just casually popped out
the bullet with a knife.
That was a fairly close range
shot, that's going deeper
than just superficial that
you can just pop it out.
Like that's going deep into your shoulder.
This is so unrealistic.
Sells that work, amazing
anime, reviewing all of that
down below. Several episodes,
click here to check it out.
And as always, Stay happy and healthy.
Green light to click on this video.